Mày, quy phang, mày, sả hơi này, hả?
Kẻ toán loàn, tổng thịm của anh,
dân thúc quá trời, đều trịp bị như thế nào, đều trịp bị như thế?
Cái bức nông đều lãng gì mà làm cái mấy tảy là?
Bằng bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy là.
Thắm đều kênh.
Chúc mình nghĩ là, bằng bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy bằng tảy.
Đó có đau.
Tìa sau đó,
Mày nằm lấy dành viên người chú chíu, thì làm cái cáo có lần rồi, đường trả hỏi ảm đàn, có thí dây
Mà có là liền
thì khi mà lần nói cái chú mình, chuyện này nữa ta
cái chú mình dành thỏi quá trảm, anh chú tật, anh đường lành trường hoàn triển, anh kim
Thì, chú em dài, đường làm, có là liền, anh bằng chú em là sao không có công em, đường trả hỏi không làm sao vậy?
Chết này, của thì không có đường trảm, cho chết một cái đòn
Giảy dòn sang quán ngon tiê em và hiểu dỉnh lạng anh Гỳ.
Dỉnh cokes để sau đối kênh gọi ngon ngon gì mạnh rồi.
Giám đặc xà ơi lời của trong ăn nữa,又.
Tình khi về truyêu hòa tờ là có thể dù lạng làm một cái chuyện hè,
nghĩa là cái vài đi đời.
Trời vào nhà.
Dạy d holy caked lệ ông ngày mà chulo obtain sự đời,
vậy em與 a sang sự thì có năm phải lo.
Ba làm tràn rận rồi, làm đời.
Vậy là các thang của những giám nó phải ký là một năm năm,
thì có tháng 1, thì có tháng 1 có tháng 1 có tháng 1.